mit dem unternehmen neue linke hat in
moskau eine krasse vision mast will
elektroden entwickeln die computer mit
dem menschlichen gehirn vernetzen und
darüber ein internet der menschlichen
gehirne erzeugen wow denn darin sieht er
die einzige chance der menschheit eine
apokalypse durch künstliche intelligenz
zu verhindern ihr habt euch dieses thema
bei whatsapp gewünschten bekommt jetzt
alle wichtigen facts zu neuling wie
sehen die pläne konkret aus und wie
realistisch sind sie wirklich das alles
und noch viel mehr in unseren willen
mars chroniken jetzt bei keksen science
fiction herzlich willkommen
in der vergangenheit ist es
verschiedenen forschungsbereichen
gelungen das menschliche gehirn schritt
für schritt zu entschlüsseln immer
wieder ist das auch thema bei uns
beispielsweise wenn es gelingt das
locked-in-patienten über eine computer
sind schnittstelle sprechen können mit
hilfe eines roboterarms blumen gießen
können oder gitarre spielen mittlerweile
sind es nicht nur mehr die kranken
menschen die im fokus des interesses von
eur und computerwissenschaften stehen
mittlerweile sind es auch gesunde
menschen denn auch ihr gehirn kann durch
technik optimiert werden
stichwort brain hecking in diesem
bereich ist auch der unternehmer allen
masc unterwegs und zwar mit seiner firma
link dir im sommer 2016 mit acht
weiteren personen gegründet hat das ziel
nervenzellen bereiche aktivieren und
ihre signale interpretieren und das in
großem stil für die masse eben eine art
hirn cloud also in der die gehirne der
menschen vernetzt werden alle gedanken
wären dann für jeden der an diesen cloud
angeschlossen ist verfügbar
aber von vorne im märz 2017 hat machte
das erste mal in der öffentlichkeit über
die pläne von eurer link gesprochen
demnach soll es nur noch wenige jahre
dauern bis die entwickelte technologie
so weit ist dass sie bereits bei
menschen mit schweren hirnschäden
eingesetzt werden kann
patienten mit gedächtnisproblemen oder
einem hirnschlag könnten so ihr gehirn
wieder effektiver nutzen
doch langfristig sind es nicht die
kranken menschen auf die maske ist mit
seinem unternehmen neuerer link
abgesehen hat es soll vor allem eine
apokalypse der künstlichen intelligenz
der ki vermieden werden vor der masse in
der nahen zukunft fahrt erinnern immer
wieder daran dass im laufe der evolution
immer wieder mal die weniger
intelligenten spezis durch die
intelligenteren verdrängt worden sind
nur wenn der mensch mit maschinen
verschwitzt und dadurch dünner schneller
und produktiver wird werden wir mast
vorstellungen zufolge nicht von der ki
abgehängt in seinen vorstellungen können
wir in einigen jahrzehnten elektronische
geräte
direkt mit unserem gehirn verbinden und
zwar mit hilfe implantierter chips im
hirn die bits und bytes in gedanken über
setzen können und umgekehrt und dafür
hat musk eine menge hochkarätiger
experten am start
angefangen bei sich selbst oft auch als
der da vinci unserer zeit bezeichnet und
wohl unbestritten einer der besten
ingenieure weltweit dazu kommt der
ehemalige chef chip designer von ibm und
noch weitere erfolgreiche erfinder nicht
zu vergessen auch einige der besten
neurochirurgen weltweit natürlich ist
das menschliche gehirn super komplex
doch im grunde funktioniert es ähnlich
wie ein computer nämlich mit hilfe von
einsen und nullen also den binärcode
eine eins steht für die aktion einer
nervenzelle die null steht für den
ruhezustand doch der große unterschied
zu computer nervenzellen verändern sich
permanent sie ordnen sich für kurze oder
lange zeit an
so können wir uns immer mehr wissen
einprägen es aber auch wieder vergessen
oder verändern
durch das so genannte machine learning
kann auch ein computer dazu lernt aber
wenn er dinge einmal kann oder weiß gibt
es keine möglichkeit dieses irgendwie
abzustufen oder abzuschwächen
diese lücke will maas mit neuling
schließen doch wie genau soll das
funktioniert was plänen sollen
elektroden direkt ins menschliche gehirn
transplantiert werden so entsteht eine
computerhirn schnittstelle so werden wir
menschen in die lage versetzt direkt mit
unserem bewusstsein in computersysteme
zu gehen lockers werden k s in solchem
fall unsere kollegen beziehungsweise
nachbarn erhofft sich dass wir sie so
verstehen und mit ihnen agieren erhofft
sich dass wir uns so in unseren
lebensraum mit der ki teilen können und
sie uns nicht gefährlich wird falls dies
alles funktioniert wird es die welt wie
wir sie kennen komplett umkrempeln
anstatt eine e mail zu tippen würde es
ausreichen einfach kurz an den
gewünschten inhalt zu denken der
computer verwandelt unsere gedanken dann
in den entsprechenden text zudem hätten
wir zugriff auf die gedanken und
erfahrungen anderer menschen
so könnten wir also problemlos die
erfahrungen von anderen erleben zum
beispiel die eines promis oder eines
soldaten
auch wenn wir bestimmtes fachwissen
haben wollen müssen wir nur an diesen
wunschdenken und
schon die gedanken entsprechende
experten herunterladen doch nicht nur
die interaktion zwischen menschen und
computern würde so komplett verändert
werden sondern auch die kommunikation
zwischen den menschen untereinander
wenn die kommunikation verliefen nach
machst läden dann direkt zwischen gehirn
und gehirn ohne datenverlust oder
verzögerung weder unser mund noch unsere
sprache werden dann mehr notwendig um
komplexe inhalte an andere zu vermitteln
also das würde dann auch die übersetzung
in texte wiederum auf dauer überflüssig
machen auch viele missverständnisse sie
durch das bloße hören von informationen
entstehen eben oder das lesen von texten
würden so von jetzt auf gleich beseitigt
klingt alles nach science-fiction pur
doch auch wenn viele experten und
expertinnen an der umsetzbarkeit dieser
vision zweifel zeigen einzelne fälle was
bereits heute schon möglich ist nehmen
wir beispielsweise querschnittsgelähmte
patienten und patientinnen die
roboterarme nur mit hilfe ihrer gedanken
steuern länger schon gibt es augen und
ohren plantage die blinden und
gehörlosen das sehen beziehungsweise was
hören ermöglicht doch ein riesiges
problem bleibt die speicherkapazität der
computersysteme denn selbst
supercomputer sind derzeit lediglich in
der lage wenige sekunden der aktivitäten
des menschlichen gehirns aufzuzeichnen
im frühling 2017 wurde bekannt dass
neuling wohl einen antrag auf die
genehmigung von tierversuchen gestellt
hat ein offizielles statement gibt es
dazu allerdings nicht bemerkenswert denn
maske ist bei all seinen anderen
aktivitäten durchaus aktiv bei twitter
und so weiter unterwegs über neuerer
link dagegen gibt es nur wenige postings
und auch die offizielle webseite ist
mehr als spärlich eventuell steckt da
der gedanke dahinter der in der tech
industrie vor allem in diesem bereich
weit verbreitet ist die dinge sollen
sich nach maggi anfühlen und nicht nach
strenger wissenschaft und tierversuchen
wie sie nun mal üblich sind auch mark
zuckerberg von facebook beispielsweise
hält sich bei seinen ambitionen ein
gehirn machine interface zu schaffen er
zurück ja wenn er als erstes neues zu
diesem thema wie neuling und so weiter
und zu allen anderen themen erfahren
wollt dann hättet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von
mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert und zu vergrössern
und gibt es ein kleines goodie das immer
wieder für freude
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der genau vergessen
wenn der glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken ihnen macht
warnt vor künstlicher intelligenz da
geht es um die ich sag mal den auslöser
die gründe für die gründung von eurer
link ansonsten bis dann bleibt